großeinsatz der polizei bei kopenhagen
am dienstag der sogenannte u boot keller
peter madsen sitzt auf dem boden und
stellt von schwer bewaffneten beamten
dänischen medienberichten zufolge soll
er um kurz nach 10 uhr aus dem
staatsgefängnis bei kopenhagen geflohen
seien seit etwa 10 30 sitz der 49
jährige am boden vor einer hecke
offenbar trägt er einen rücksack einem
gürtel und droht damit bei einem polizei
zugriff eine bombe zu zünden mehrere
gefängniswächter sollen madsen nach
seiner flucht nach gelaufen sein er soll
es rund 500 meter weit geschafft haben
bis die polizei ihn umringte peter
madsen wurde zu einer gefängnisstrafe
von 20 jahren verurteilt nachdem er die
journalistin cam ward 2017 aus seinem
u-boot ermordet und zerstückelt hatte
mehr nachrichten um breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren